you wrote a post about levels of
lucidity
quote as we grow older it becomes
apparent that our self-reflexive mind is
not just gradually accumulating ideas
about itself but that it progresses in
somewhat distinct stages
so there's seven of the stages stage one
reactive survival infant
stage two personal self young child
stage three social self adolescence
domesticated adult stage four is
rational agency self-direction stage
five is self
authoring that's full adult you've
achieved wisdom but there's two more
stages stage six is Enlightenment stage
seven is Transcendence can you explain
each
or the interesting parts of each of
these stages and what's your sense why
their stages
of this uh of Lucidity as we progress
through life in this too short life this
model is derived from concept by the
psychologist Robert Keegan and he talks
about the development of the self as a
process that happens in principle by
some kind of reverse engineering of a
mind where you gradually become aware of
yourself and thereby build structure
that allows you to interact deeper with
the world and yourself
and I found myself using this model not
so much as a developmental model I'm not
even sure if it's a very good
developmental model because I saw my
children not progressing exactly like
that and I also suspect that you don't
go to these stages necessarily in
succession and it's not that you work
through one stage and then you get into
the next one sometimes you revisit them
sometimes stuff is happening in parallel
but it's I think a useful framework to
look at what's present in the structure
of a person and how they interact with
the world and how they relate to
themselves
so it's more like a philosophical
framework that allows you to talk about
how mines work and at first when we are
born we don't have a personal self yet I
think instead we have an intentional
self and this attention itself is
initially in the infant task that's
building a world model and also an
initial model of the staff but mostly
it's building a game engine in the brain
that is tracking sensory data and uses
it to explain it and in some sense you
could compare it to game engine like
Minecraft or so so colors and sounds
people are all not physical objects they
are creation of our mind at a certain
level of core screening models that are
mathematical that use geometry and that
use manipulation of objects and so on to
create scenes in which we can find
ourselves to interact with them so
Minecraft yeah and this personal self is
something that is more or less created
after the world is finished after it's
trained into the system after it has
been constructed and this personal self
is an agent that interacts with the
outside world and the outside world is
not the world of quantum mechanics the
not the physical universe but it's the
model that has been generated in our own
mind
right and this is us and we experience
ourselves interacting the stead outside
world that is created inside of our own
mind and outside of our self there's
feelings and then they presented our
interface to this outside world they
pose problems to us these feelings are
basically attitudes that our mind is
Computing that tell us what's needed in
the world the things that we are drawn
to or the things that we are afraid of
and we are tasked with solving this
problem of satisfying the needs avoiding
the aversions following on our inner
commitments and so on and also modeling
ourselves and building the next stage so
after we have this personal self and
stage two online many people form a
social self and this social self allows
the individual to experience themselves
as part of a group
it's basically this thing that when you
are playing in a team for instance you
don't notice yourself just as a single
note that is reaching out into the world
but you're also looking down you're
looking down from this entire group and
you see how this group is looking at
this individual and everybody in the
group is in some sense emulating this
group Spirit to some degree and in this
state people are forming their opinions
by assimilating them from this group
mind obviously gain the ability to act a
little bit like a hive mind but are you
also modeling the interaction of how
opinions shapes and forms through the
interaction of the individual nodes
within the group
yeah it's basically the way in which
people do it in this stage is that they
experience what are the opinions of my
environment they experience the
relationship that they have to the
environment and they resonate with
people around them and get more opinions
in this through this interaction to um
the way in which they relate to others
and at stage four you basically
understand that stuff is true and false
independently what other people believe
and you have agency over your own
beliefs in that stage you basically
discover epistemology the rules about
determining what's true and false so you
can you start to learn how to think
yes I mean at some level you're always
thinking you are constructing things and
they believe that this ability to reason
about your mental representation is what
we mean by thinking it's an
intrinsically reflexive process that
requires Consciousness without
Consciousness you cannot think you can
generate the content of feelings and so
on outside of Consciousness it's very
hard to be conscious of how your
feelings emerge at least in the early
stages of development but um thoughts is
something that you always control
and if you are a nerd like me
you often have to skip stage three
because you'd like the intuitive empathy
with others because in order to resonate
with a group you need to have a quite
similar architecture and if people are
wired differently then it's hard for
them to resonate with other people and
basically have empathy which is not the
same as compassion but it is a shared
perceptual mental state empathy happens
not just via inference about the mental
states of others but it's a perception
of what other people feel and where
they're at can't you not have empathy
while also not having a similar
architecture cognitive architecture as
the others I think yes but I experience
that too but you need to build something
that is like a meta architecture you
need to be able to embrace the
architecture of the other to some degree
also find some common ground and it's
also this issue that if you are a nerd
Nomis often so people is in neurotypical
people have difficulty to resonate with
you and as a result they have difficult
the understanding you unless they have
enough wisdom to to fear what's going on
there